[Music]
[Music]
good morning guys
welcome to our last day in Japan oh it's
a little sad I love this place and it
breaks my heart every time to leave so I
do miss my two little boys that are with
Grandma and Grandpa
and I'm anxious to see them apparently
Jacob got his first teeth while we were
gone they got a bulging bag full of
presents and clothes and then we got my
the two of fishing bags that I bought
which are both bulging full of fishing
gear do you want to go catch a carp yeah
we're gonna go get Tommy one fish we got
about 1 hour to do it and we got to get
out of Japan then all right we're here
at the river and I can already see big
carp sitting right there through a
little test piece out get him he's
looking at it oh you decided no these
fish are really shy today for some
reason well guys we're out of bread
we're out of time we need to get out of
here carp really hooked shy today we got
one hook brief hook up couple of bites
but they were just pecking at it hey
Tommy you having a good time
today's a holiday and our neighbors are
out here and the kids are out going to
try to catch a cup of the mushi and
Tommy's sharing some popsicles with them
well guys this is it we're packed up and
leaving Japan Becca's just turning
lights off and turning off the air
conditioning we're sad to leave are we I
hope so
we've got a taxi driver with a strong
back you know and a good attitude
because he got all those bags in the
trunk with bungee cords and everything I
was very impressed
we got three reserved tickets for the
express fancy first-class train to the
airport we're gonna grab some food and
try not to stress out too much
was the most fun you had in Japan was it
the monkey Park or writing on the by for
ads I refined everything
that was fun we end up getting here way
early so we got three hours to kill
before boarding so we're just looking
around Tommy's been saying that he wants
to go see Nathan I don't blame him
I miss Nathan the digging - all right
we're gonna grab some lunch you get the
airport hold buckwheat noodles tempura
shrimp
surprise egg it's got curry udon noodles
with deep fried pork cutlet on top yeah
well the sato family came to the airport
to see us off and give one last goodbye
so we're gonna go get some ice cream and
and just spend a few more moments with
them
oh no Tommy's trying to use his
Kamehameha powers children correos [ __ ]
not everyone got one of those I'm tool
cousin Wilhelmina okay look what they
have Tommy soda with marbles in it you
want one again - here we are at the
Osaka Airport and
all right Tommy stop attacking people
okay
okay
oh man I'm sad to leave what a fun trip
and I think one of the best parts is
listening to Tommy say domo arigato
gozai a moustache to everybody nailed it
guys check this out we got no one
flavour ET caps and strawberries it gets
you I get that will owe me I get I got a
big pile of ten cent coins here all
right we've got peach Kalfas and goun
goun the yogurt though yeah it's
actually pretty good actually heading
back it's bittersweet I am too
the Japanese are so nice they even gave
me a free massage on the way through
security buddy we're going all the way
that number 49
the bud take off it's a little after
5:00 p.m. and we're going to land around
noon so we are about to enter a time
machine troops it's been about 11 hours
and we're just about to land in LA
American Airlines just bumped our flight
back three hours you know just like yeah
sorry by the way you're still paying 100
bucks extra for baggage
well we've been here at LAX for six
hours now yeah
hopefully hopefully soon soon beginning
heading to Salt Lake
oh there's my my fishing rods
where's my boys who wants to see
presents check this out it's a talking
owl I can take over this our little dog
it's little sheep I can
here's your teach it was just what we
come out Tommy where did you get these
let me look at you look at your gym day
you look so
[Music]
little Jacob it is jimbe with little
frogs on it maybe that it's a Pikachu
fishing rod you know what these are this
is how samurais practice do you like him
are they cool okay tomorrow morning
we're gonna get to swordfight but
tonight we gotta get ready for bed it's
past your bedtime well we got the kids
to bed they're asleep with their little
Jim BAE's on and it is really late it's
like 11:30 and I have not slept much and
I will see you guys in the morning
it's a beautiful morning here in Salt
Lake City it's about 8:30 in the morning
and I woke up to a little Nathan jumping
up on our bed very excited to see mommy
and daddy I'm gonna walk to the local
grocery store here pick up some food
all right got the groceries got a little
exercise I'm gonna head back to the
house you know traveling around has
taught me that there's something special
about wherever you go there's things
that are awesome about America there's
things that are awesome about Japan and
I think the key to enjoying yourself is
appreciating whatever special about
wherever you're at and today that means
maple brown sugar breakfast sausage
leeks
hey little Jacob good morning are you
ready for breakfast
one of the things I missed the most
about the USA is American breakfast yeah
it tastes good guys yeah okay we
finished breakfast and for the last
three hours I've been planning to go
fishing with the boys but I am
profoundly tired
check this out grandpa's bringing his a
game here
[Music]
there's grandpa taking Tommy for a walk
[Music]
[Music]
it took me about four hours to get
enough energy together to get up off the
couch and off the floor I am pretty
exhausted but we're gonna go fishing
aren't we guys all right guys we're here
at Willow Park and Murray Utah I've
never fished here before so I hear this
catfish in here may be some bull heads
and trout
and look at these guys over here show me
how it's done that's what your third one
here in the last what our good for you
man it's a nice fish I got a couple
extra if you come here get a fish come
here get a fish
yeah you got up you got him keep going
real as fast you can
whoa come on fight him buddy put your
back into it okay you could stop really
neat all right Ethan
there you go buddy one two three wolf
[Music]
your face to camera Tom all right
beautiful Tom
okay doing good dog
all right time that's enough reeling now
we just walk it backwards walk it
backwards
[ __ ] all right there we go ah yes it's
the longest one I is the biggest one
we've had so far look he knows whiskers
on him yeah five fish on and landed four
that's a pretty successful day all the
boys got a reel in a catfish I think mom
wants to go out to dinner tonight
that sounds fun guys go to a restaurant
all right cool let's do it
I think somebody got tuckered out
fishing what do you think all right guys
come on wake up all right my little boy
he got his first haircut today well we
ate a nice dinner got the kids to bed at
8:45 so first time in a while that
they've been to bed just normal and I
think we're gonna follow suit I'm
exhausted
it's 1:00 p.m. and I finally put pants
on it's that kind of day guys oh my
goodness I'm so tired
around 2:30 in the morning last night
Tommy came into her bedroom said he
couldn't sleep this is all jet lag
and I got him to bedroom 4 a.m. finally
got him to go to sleep and then I
couldn't sleep until 5:00 a.m. or
someplace yeah I just gotta power
through today we're finally getting off
the couch out of the house we're gonna
go up to Snowbird and check some stuff
out anything you ready to go on a little
venture
[Music]
one kill hey-ho thanks Becky
alright so we're at the Snowbird ski
resort here you go take the tram up to
the top might be some restaurant up
there or something
I'm just come along for the ride today
[Music]
you guys see these grizzly bears
well here we are in the top of Snowbird
have no idea what this mountains called
but the resorts called Snowbird so there
it is Hidden Peak well it's not very
hidden I haven't been skiing in a long
time I actually like the mono board too
if you're a child you can always tell
how hardcore of a fan they are just when
they should say hi if there's someone
who's like a casual viewer like dude you
that guy from the internet and if
they're there a moderate fan they'll be
like oh dude do cats and carp if they're
serious like the boys want to ride the
chairlift down the mountain with me and
we need to measure them to see if
they're the required 42 inches where I
decided just for the heck of it to go
and walk down to a chairlift and take a
chairlift down and tear lift closes in
like 10 minutes and we got to make it
down this mountain we've got a fat old
man and an ambitious little boy and
we're gonna see if we can get down there
before he gets stuck all right we got
two minutes dumb two minutes oh you can
do it I'm dying
Patel pioneered of in the hold on dear
Lucy mama
my other cousins we came up here
look up there that's mommy and grandma
grandpa there we race you to see any
moose or bears yeah are you so scared I
was like touch them Menka wants to try
the little mountain coaster and the
zipline thing for Giggy so where you go
see if we can't hunt down some
[Music]
good job buddy
me and Nate are gonna chill here for a
little bit we had a good time on the
mountain coaster and Rebecca and Tommy
have got passes to do that zipline
thingamajiggy Hey
[Music]
here we go
we're gonna put the kids to bed then I'm
gonna put myself to bed and knock on
wood tonight's gonna go a little bit
smoother and I wake up a little bit more
energized tomorrow mmm
we're gonna get some breakfast well I
got breakfast squared away
[Music]
all right guys you ready let's go
fishing
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that's that's a little bit of a
sandstorm all right I'm gonna go check
it out real quick okay this is you
ballet in central Utah and we are in the
desert I hear that they have mirror carp
here that sure looks like a very dead
mirror carp to me this is kind of an
intense place to fish loads of flies see
that's a common carp right there it's
another dead carp and tons of small
sized dead carp by the ways guys to give
you an idea of how much of a drought
they have here you can see here the map
thinks I'm right in the middle of the
lake needless to say the water level has
dropped a lot that's the shoreline way
back up there the original shoreline 96
degrees out there's flies everywhere
it's windy there's sandstorms being
kicked up the water used to be look at
that guy's there's about 12 or 15 carp
right there just tons of them
the boys really want to use their
Pikachu rods little common car
congratulations Nathan do you like that
was that fun all right let's let them go
shall we uh Nathan Nathan you got one
[Music]
I'm not sure whether they both have one
or they just cross each other's lines
but now you guys got to fish that's two
fish okay you guys and your crazy double
all right there we go
well we've caught four fish in 15
minutes and so I'm not even gonna pull
out my rod it's just that would just be
insanity we're just gonna let the boys
use the pokemons rods and have a ball
hey another great another great little
common carp there oh yeah nice mirror
carp the fish are just jumping like
crazy I've probably seen 20 30 carp jump
yep see there's one right there
don't eat the mate I thought you would
grow up past that oh that kid loves to
eat my bait get it get it he's right by
ya another gorgeous mirror carp back in
Virginia
I only catch about one or two of these a
year now you catch a grasshopper by
yourself yeah on rocks I just like kind
of again again and again well I think we
caught about 15 16 fish and the boys
I've just completely given up on fishing
and are just swimming but these little
half Alaskans are gonna crisp up nicely
in the Sun so we better I think we
better get them home here in a little
bit plus we have a long drive back back
to the house oh wait a minute
is that your diaper oh wait a minute
you're naked okay
Nathan's going full nudists on us what
you're naked did you guys have a fun
time oh good all right let's go get you
guys some food we're driving back to the
house and I'm gonna swing by an
important historic landmark
you caught my very first car Pierre is
about a 10-pound white koi on a fly rod
now there should be like a statue or a
plaque but they haven't quite got that
up yet so we'll have to calls make some
phone calls so I know why that here's
another important landmark this is the
apartment complex where me and Rebecca
met and later got married all right guys
we're home we made it my wife's brother
Matt Uncle Matt is visiting here and I
think we're lucky the boys will talk
them into some kendo sword fighting
sword fight with the boys
you've always want to hit one of the
kids we know it come on so bad did you
ever think you'd be sword fighting a
toddler and die first today the Uncle
Matt's a good sport for letting you
sword fight with them
okay go get these packed up we're
leaving tomorrow all right we gotta get
these kids to bed I'm tired well the
kids had a great time with their uncle
Matt and we finally got him down to bed
and now I'm trying to get everything
squared away cuz we're headed to Alaska
tomorrow afternoon and I've got to get
all my bags repack after the Japan trip
and there's lots of little knickknacks
we picked up along the way so I've got a
you know shuffle things around and
figure out how to fit everything in all
of our bags without going over weight or
having to pay for more bags so we'll
sort it out maybe we'll run to the post
office tomorrow mail some stuff back to
Virginia but I'll see you guys tomorrow
morning thanks for watching we hope you
enjoyed this video check out this sneak
peek of the next installment of the 2018
world tour
we like this video log series don't
forget to click the playlist link into
the video description below thanks for
watching if you want to see more great
videos from the outdoor boys YouTube
channel don't forget to click Subscribe
we put out new videos every Saturday
morning